night Ron night
Ron ladies
ladies
[Applause]
[Music]
I found this typewriter next to the
Courtyard dumpster an old Underwood five
with original carriage
return took her home polished her up
bought a brand new ribbon off of
electronic bay.com
okay somebody's got to do something I'm
getting a cluster headache oh he's
leaving let's go I'm going to throw it
away no I'm not it weighs a billion tons
what is he typing anyway if you sons of
try to remove this typewriter
I'll kill
you I'm going to type every word I
know re
rectangle
America
megaphone
Monday
butthole Ron did you get my text no did
you get my emails mm did you see that I
paged you I did not did you check your
voicemail I didn't we have a criminal
emergency in our hands someone planted a
gateway drug in the community garden
okay call the cops that'll lead to the
Press then there'll be an investigation
and they'll find my fingerprints on the
manure and then we'll lose our funding
you don't have funding and we never will
if this gets out look I will call the
cops but just give me one day to deal
with this internally okay sure thank you
and listen if this thing blows up I was
never
here I have a hernia I've had it for a
while and I've been ignoring it
successfully but uh this morning
I made the mistake of
sneezing but as long as I sit still and
don't move my
head or
torso I'm good I got
this
April yeah get my lunch for me please
okay like order you something no get it
from there
is this some kind of weird Power
Trip
please thank you that'll be all you're
welcome yo I had to wait till my dad
fell asleep so I could steal his keys
ready I was born
ready I'm Ron
Swanson easy
care
careful you really shouldn't have dug
that out of the dumpster I had to also I
had a banana on the way over here sorry
and I get why you don't want want anyone
to know about Duke silver and you don't
have to worry your secret is safe with
me to even it out I'm going to tell you
all of my secrets oh no that's not
necessary I once forgot to brush my
teeth for 5 weeks I didn't actually sell
my last car I just forgot where I parked
it I don't know who Al Gore is and at
this point I'm too afraid to ask when
they say 2% milk I don't know what the
other 98% is when I was a baby my head
was so big scientist it experiments on
me I once threw a beer at a swan and
then it attacked my niece re
that'll do Andrew you don't have to play
the Unity Concert but don't quit music
please every year I give Leslie the same
present I give everyone a crisp $20 bill
and every year she gets me something
thoughtful and personal it makes me
Furious this year she outdid
herself
she had it installed over the
weekend
so so beautiful that of an ex-wife
is working for the library now that is
perfect the worst person in the world
working at the worst place in the world
I have to go talk to her and you got to
give me something I can use does she
have any
weaknesses no what do you mean no
everybody has a weakness not machines I
honestly believe that she was programmed
by someone from the future to come back
and destroy all happiness I see just I
knew that you had two Ex-Wives named
Tammy so I was hoping that there was one
that you got along with and no I hate
them both on my deathbed my final wish
is to have my Ex-Wives rush to my side
so I can use my dying breath to tell
them both to go to hell one last time
would I get married again oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of
living
Ron
Ron last name
done is that your name or are you
telling me you're finished talking
both done and
done I like Ron let's talk plans for
Diane's baby shower dear God woman three
main activities baby bingo baby food
tasting and my personal favorite baby
onesie decorating station I'm going to
make mine look like an astronaut what
are you doing up there in space baby oh
so cute okay I have some gift ideas I
was looking at a very adorable stroller
we already have a stroller oh shoot
really I have to think of something
else oh my God whose baby is that that
would be mine guys get in here Ron has a
baby oh Ron cool baby thank you Andrew
everyone I'd like to introduce you to my
son John middle name redacted Swanson
John was born some time ago weighing
multiple pounds and several ounces much
like his father he is a fan fan of
silence please keep your voices down how
am I supposed to keep my voice down when
you had your baby and you didn't tell me
that you had your baby why would you
need to know something like that why
would I oh my God I have not even sent
Dian a gift she's just walking around
wondering why I haven't sent her a gift
yet should we do something just let her
Tire herself out if you need anything
from usan please just let us know
actually there is something could one of
you please stop by the pet store and
pick up some fish food for me when did
you get a fish
Ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plenty
no you need to drink water usually I
take it neat but I will make an
exception in the name of Health last
night I watched a movie with Diane and
the girls in which an orange fish is
separated from his father the children
were sniffling which I believe to be due
to the sad nature of the
film I was
wrong you need to take off off those
layers rehydrate and go to the doctor
thank you for your concern I will be
fine please turn the thermostat up to 90
and leave me alone Ron this isn't safe I
am a grown man I have had a cold before
I need no help so if you don't
mind that seems about
right hey you look better I guess actual
medicine can be effective who to thk
please leave me alone not until we go
over your test results and your blood
work your blood pressure looks fine not
sure how this is possible but your
cholesterol is 120 which is the lowest
I've ever seen what's cholesterol and
the only problem I see is that your
potassium's low so just eat a banana
once in a while no thank you I live the
way I live I eat the things I eat and
I'll die the way I'll
die I want to be your assistant really
you hate it here so do you I'll make
sure you don't have to go go to any
meetings if anyone comes to see you I'll
scare them away wait April if you had to
choose between these two
ties you're
hired libertarianism is all about
individual liberty and it should never
be defined by the terms liberal or
conservative and communism is no good
that's right big swing in a Miss yeah
and what's the word for when a few
clerics are in
charge religious oligarchy holy huh
I can remember things I
guess Andy keep mine rare a man after my
own
heart